let's take a closer look at the
situation on the ground in ukraine now
and i'm here with retired air vice
marshal sean bell sean great to see you
as always uh we're gonna start with the
snapshot of all of ukraine and just talk
us through the key areas of focus in the
in the days ahead yeah well i think the
um the initial let's start with mario
paul as your chorus wants to be talking
about um a desperate situation there the
shelling is continuing reports that some
of the civilians are managing to get out
but so far the numbers are tens and
twenties rather than the thousands that
we believe are in there so it's still
looking pretty bleak for them at kharkiv
up to the north here um lots of examples
of ukrainian counter-attacks up there
why is that important because part of
the resupply route for the russian main
effort in dot mass is to the south of
there and therefore anything that the
ukrainians can do to put at risk the
russian resupply routes will give the
russians something to think about if we
move further south carson um as we've
heard we've seen the russians are
consolidating there and uh finally at
isian which is where the fierce is
fighting the main focus is happening at
the moment but it does appear to have
ground to a halt let's uh let's dive in
a bit into isiam then so this area to
the east of the country and talk us
through what sort of fighting is going
going on around here and the tactics
involved yeah well south of isian the
what seems to be occurring is the
russians are trying to push their troops
further south they both are using two
main road routes from south of isiam for
some reason and why they're using the
two main route roads if you remember up
at kiev we had that big 40 mile convoy
that was made them very vulnerable to
attack but it appears this time of year
that the off-road terrain is not well
suited for heavy armor
or some of the other vehicles they have
so they've largely confined themselves
to the roads and of course that makes
them very vulnerable to counter-attack
from the ukrainians and by all accounts
they've stalled what the russians are
desperately trying to do is reinforce
from belgrade down to the south but of
course kharkiv is causing some issue
issues there why is this key though in
the battle it's key because any
attacking force wants to maintain
momentum with momentum you have
initiative as soon as you stall you
effectively hand the initiative to your
opposition and ukraine will not be slow
to mount counter attacks and potentially
even isolate some of the leading
elements of the russian uh forces so
that's the focused uh in in the east
let's also just quickly have a look at
some of the key areas in the south and
why have you
picked out this map to highlight what's
going on here this week well a lot of
our attention has been out to the east
um for the last week with the main focus
of the battle in the donbass region but
of course fighting does continue across
a broader swathe of ukraine if russia
still ultimately desires to take the
whole of this coastland and take odessa
then cursor will be an important
stepping stone for that and we've also
seen recently the bombing i think
overnight the bombing of the airfield at
odessa and recently we've seen satellite
imagery of quite a number of troops and
their equipment russian troops and
equipment in cursing and of course also
the announcement as your colleagues have
been reporting of new administrative
controls and potentially the ruble being
used in cursing all this is somewhat
disturbing except for the fact two
points one of which the more russian
troops are locked in person they're
fixed and they're not able to support
the main effort in the donbass and
secondly whilst they are fixed there
ukrainians are taking full advantage to
do counter-attacks and there are several
reports and many of the suburbs of
cursor now being back into ukrainian
control so the battle for cursing isn't
over and certainly if russia aspired to
take odessa that's not going to happen
anytime soon sean bell as always thanks
so much